hello youtubers i'm laura tyson
professor of economics and business at
the university of california berkeley i
can think of two things in two quite
different areas one i think it is
important for the central banks and a
number of countries of the world to get
together to try to make sure that the
world doesn't enter a global recession
in 2008 I think there are things they
can do I think a kind of international
agreement of coordination of
macroeconomic policy and exchange rate
efforts could be very helpful at the
same time I think at a personal level
what each individual who think about
ways that they can make a mean for
reduction in their use of carbon-based
energy I think there are a lot of
low-hanging fruit in our lives in terms
of efficiencies famines I think if we do
that in our homes and our officers in
our travels and we get others to do the
same thing but we'll be making progress
on the greatest challenge then confronts
humanity and that is the global climate
change challenge